hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game also from round one of this
year's Baku open uh it is a video master
from
kazakhstanva against the international
Master uh from Uzbekistan Abdi Malik
Abdi salimov and it's a really wild game
as I mean of course it is you guys
requested it features uh some very
interesting moves features maybe even a
sacrifice of a very valuable piece uh so
let's dive straight into it and see what
this is about Leah has the white pieces
and she opens with Ponte E4 we have Pawn
to G6 and now Pawn to D4 just grabbing
the full Center we have Bishop to G7 uh
Knight the C3 and D6 going for the
modern modern defense or or the robot
and it's uh it's a fairly popular
opening nowadays even uh amongst the top
Grand masters with Ponte F4 and now
Ponte A6 you have uh I've seen this many
times even on this channel we've shown a
couple of games by Magnus also uh if you
guys remember Hikaru Nakamura won a very
nice this game with the black pieces
with this exact same setup against
vishwanathan in 2018 it was a Blitz game
but still a very nice game and they
continue uh in following that game for
quite a few moves Knight F3 we have
Quantum B5 Bishop to D3 and now Bishop
to uh B7 putting pressure on that E4
Pawn we have Ponte A4 and pawn to B4 as
black has to decide what to do with that
pawn whether to capture whether to
advance or whether to do nothing and
just wait for a capture some B5 which is
not great as that B5 square is being
pressured a lot so here are Knight back
to E2 and now Knight to D7 we have
castles and pawn to C5 so all
very nicely done by both of them Pawn to
C3 and now uh we have Knight the H6 here
in the game that I mentioned um uh Anand
versus Nakamura big characters and C3
was played but here we have Knight to H6
and now uh there are a few games that
reach this position A5 is a normal
Knight the G3 is a known move uh but
here we have Ponte H3 and it is now as
of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game so let's see uh how uh he
continues after H3 we have castles and
now Pawn to G4 just going all out here
not um and not looking back and uh there
are a lot of candidate moves you could
consider here you consider beat captures
on C3 you could consider C character
Sandy for you could consider sort of a
king DJ the nice uh a nice waiting move
improving the position of your pieces
but he goes for Pawn to F5 it looks like
a pawn sacrifice but it's not he's gonna
win the pawn back and it's gonna open up
his dark Square Bishop to to attack so
this is what Abdi Malik wants we have
characters on F5 captures on F5 and now
Pawn to G5 this is how she uh kicks away
the Knight to grab the F5 Pawn Knight to
F7 Bishop captures and F5 and now he
just wins it back Knight captures and G5
attacks the bishop here The Rook is not
threatening to pick up the bishop Knight
captures on G5 Rook captures on F5 and
now Knights the G3 attacking the
attacking the rook and the best way to
defend is Rook to F6 this keeps an eye
on all the all the key squares but he
played Rook to D5 and now uh look at
what happens Queen to G4 and this is a
this is a very scary move the problem is
uh if you if black plays a animal here
like uh B captures on C3 you just get
checkmated Queen to E6 with Chuck once
the king moves Knight to F7 check with a
monster Fork here and for those of you
who are maybe new to chess not only does
black lose a queen here he also gets
checkmated with a uh beautiful smothered
mate King dh8927 checking G8 and now a
nice double check Knight to H6 King goes
back and now of course Queen to G8 and
you give up the queen for this beautiful
Checkmate for those of you who haven't
seen it I'm sure I will appreciate this
so after Queen to G4 uh he decides that
he has to give some material Rook
captures and G5 is played F captures on
G5 and now C capture Sun D4 and okay you
still have to be very careful you want
some material uh but uh he does have the
bishop pair uh it's uh you know
definitely fully operational and if he
can get that Knight into the game maybe
bring the queen uh somewhere to C7 to B6
Rook to fade the Knight comes to E5
could be very dangerous so here we have
C captures on D4 and queen to B6 now
putting pressure on the king here and
now uh you could play something like
Bishop T3 which of course makes sense uh
here she goes for Knights the F5 uh
which defends the the pawn here and
threatens Knight captures anise an E7
amongst other things so here we have
Knight the E5 attacking the queen here
the problem is if you play something
like E6 and of course you can do this
you try to attack the Knight and if the
Knight moves then you're gonna capture
on D4 the problem is there's Knight to
H6 check and now you can't uh capture
you're getting checkmated so you have to
play King the a trade and now just
Knight to F7 check and after the king
moves now you play Bishop D3
everything's defended there's no real
counter play here from black so instead
uh Knight the E5 was played attacking
the White Queen here and this is only
the first pause the video moment uh
there are two very nice ones so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only winning idea for Leah well I'll
give you a couple of seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on you're really
using the entire board to solve this one
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is actually Pawn to A5
this is the move that slows the position
and uh once once you see it of course
you also believe it the problem is how
do you defend if you play something like
Queen G3 and just want to wait it out uh
let's say Knight to G6 how do you
continue of course you have to go uh
Bishop to E3 but now just Queen to C6
and the white is also in in some trouble
here you can't really do anything the
these seven Pawn is nicely defended you
don't have really a move here and you
solve all of this by playing A5 because
in that line that we've just shown black
will not have Queen to C6 uh White wins
a valuable Tempo and everything works
out very well so now Queen to A7 was
played if you play Queen to C6 now then
you no longer uh pin pin the d-pawn so
white can just capture the Knight and uh
although it's similar to what happened
in the game it is someone different
let's say queen to H1 Chuck King death 2
you can give a few more checks King D1
and queen captures on E5 but now you
just block Europe full Rook of course
there's no point in uh continuing this
with with black so instead Queen the A7
was played and now comes Queen to G3
getting the queen out of Harm's Way and
now uh now Knight to G6 will be met with
Bishop D3 so black has to do something
here he plays Pawn to E6 uh but Leah
just plays Knight captures on G7 and how
can black reply here here king a queen
captures on D4 check was played because
if you take the piece then Bishop T3
comes uh no longer you have to worry
about this diagonal the Knight is attack
the left and ig6 now even Pawn to D5
attacking the queen putting pressure on
E6 once you move the queen then you
capture here Rook to F7 is coming and
again a total collapse for black
optimally cannot afford this so after
Knight captures on G7 he played Queen
captures on D4 with check now comes
Bishop to E3 attacks the queen queen to
E4 now going for Queen to H1 uh but now
comes Knight the H5 and interestingly
this is the only winning move Knight to
H5 you have to play this now you're
threatening Knight to F6 check with the
fork and black really has to go for uh
for this check first king to h8 was
played to avoid the fork but now even
now Knight to F6 attacks the queen queen
to H1 check King to F2 and now Queen
back to C6 if you continue Knight to D3
check King T2 and there's no way to
continue the attack so that's why uh he
goes back at Queen to C6 now comes Rook
a to D1 uh we have rooked the C8 and now
Rook the D2 stopping any any checks on
the second rank we have Queen to C4 uh
just uh you know nicely and nicely
controlling squares with the queen uh
and now King to G1 we have Queen to C6
again going for that King the queen to
H1 with check but just King to H2 this
avoids everything we have rooked the C7
controlling the seventh rank uh but now
for the second and last time feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Leah that while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on solving uh well if
you saw the first one then big
congratulations on solving the second
one as well but even if you install the
first one this one is quite nice so
congratulations on uh you know giving
giving it your best uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course Queen captors and E5 this
is how she finishes the game and it's
quite a beautiful way to finish it uh at
that there's no good way to reply here
like you could play something like Queen
to G2 to you know be funny about it and
maybe to prolong the game a little bit
uh but the captors on E5 was played and
now comes Rook 38 with check uh you
don't have a move you could give them
the queen which is silly so King the G7
was played now comes uh you don't want
to mess up the game with Rook to G8 to
check it seems like solves all of your
problems but King to F7 and now you no
longer have a have a Checkmate uh and
you will you will be losing this game so
here at night the H5 check was played
this is the only way to uh to Checkmate
the black king king to G6 now comes to
Rook to F6 with check and he was in this
position on move 36 that abdemonic
abdisalimov resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here the only
move he has for his King is King
captures on H5 which would be met with
Elias uh Rook to H6 Checkmate and this
would be uh the the final position of
the game so really an awesome game uh
really really tricky stuff if you play
the robots you have to be prepared for
everything he is uh well he's much
higher rated than her so of course he
wanted to to have an active game to
increase his winning chances but it
didn't really work out uh and in the end
he had to give up the exchange and then
he even uh blundered the well not
boundary it was it was a bad position
and then he just had to you know play
something and then Queen captures on E5
just a spectacular way to finish the
game uh so yeah there we have it hope
you guys enjoyed it another very nice
game from one around one of this year's
uh back will open if you have any other
games that you would like to see covered
use hashtag suggestion in the comments I
will go over them and if it you know
seems like something that people will
enjoy and of course if I enjoy it then I
will go over it for for everyone else to
enjoy uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Russell Jack Wesley Carter Mark
bootsakaki uh kid tester and Edmond
Freeman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day